the idea is to create
um
mass content that is you know
high-end realistic fast easy and
cost-effective
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community
fund in silicon valley in partnership
with lumitec sponsored by homeward
ventures hippo insurance oppos labs
synergy global hillel at stanford leap
birthright excel serena partners and in
media partnership with c-tech
welcome ron kern co-founder and ceo of
augmind
from a ba in computer science and
business in israel to masters in cs from
bu ron then spent a decade on wall
street and then back to israel for
another decade in technology startups
focusing on creating unique and
strategic alliances
run is now geared at setting new
boundaries for augmented reality content
and apps and set new standards for what
you are about to see digitally with the
goal of paving the way for mass ar
adaption
ron kern welcome to 20 minute leaders
how are you today
good good hi michael thank you very much
thanks for having me thank you for
having me in these next 20 minutes uh
talking about one of my favorite
subjects um you know zuckerberg recently
started talking about the metaverse and
everybody's going crazy so obviously you
know anybody that's working on augmented
reality mixed reality worlds and this is
you know the time to do so and that's
why i'm very excited to have this
conversation right now you're the
co-founder and ceo of ogmind and and i'm
excited to hear a little bit about you
know what that what the company is doing
but even before that you know taking a
look at your background you've done a
lot of different things and most of them
not even related to augmented reality
and mixed reality
so tell me a little bit about you know
your own background and how you ended up
converging into this augmented reality
space
sure
um it started in israel you know
academics it was a bachelor's in
computer science and in admin and then
uh moved to boston went to grad school
at boston university and that did my
master's in computer science there and
then it worked for another decade on
wall street uh so a whole different
background all together
i was working with all the major hedge
funds all the big banks and then about a
decade ago i moved back to startup
nation to tel aviv israel
and did a switch from you know financial
wall street to working on attic startups
and so forth
and about five years ago um
i started to you know um implement and
start working with mixed reality
technologies it was interesting trying
to bring the attic world into mixed
reality which was you know way ahead of
its time back then but that's kind of
like when i started to you know play
with these technologies and it was so
interesting and you know was
mind-boggling back at the you know even
today but then you know you think about
so many different things that you know
where where you can take it and so forth
and augmented reality was you know just
you know getting started you know with
its big boom
virtual reality has been around also but
was in predominantly in games and then
later on ar is starting to be you know
implemented across a lot of different
you know industries and across a lot of
different verticals
so deciding to create this new company
in augmented reality
now why now so you started mentioning
about everything that's happening you
know the you know with the world but you
know why is this the best time for you
as an entrepreneur to go and say yes i'm
ready this is the best time for us to do
what we're doing
actually um let's go let's uh backtrack
for a second we started the company
about three and a half years ago
so it was ahead of its time you know and
then back then you know we were trying
to pitch the investor is what we're
trying to do and it was really early so
it was really difficult to understand
what we were trying to accomplish back
then
nowadays it's a whole different story um
you mentioned zuckerberg earlier and you
know we're seeing a lot of big companies
trying to
bring us into these technologies uh some
focus on the hardware and the air
glasses in vr glasses and the head mount
display and so forth and all those on
content metaverse being part of it and
so forth
and
it's tricky you know it sounds uh it
sounds charming and it sounds awesome
but there's a lot of different
challenges along the way
and from the get-go we were set to you
know make it easier for everyone to do
so
um so when when we started a little bit
early but nowadays it makes sense
because what we're essentially trying to
do is make ar creation the content
creation and app development easier for
everyone um if you're looking at like
experienced people skillful people today
that are hard to find um and they're you
know they're a must when it comes to
creating content and apps for these kind
of
um
technologies and for you know building
metaverse and so forth um argument is
essentially building up platforms it's
easier for
um
not necessarily experienced people to do
it students from university there's a
very short learning curve and so forth
we can get into it in a second but the
idea is to create
mass content that is you know
high-end realistic
fast easy and cost-effective
so the adaptation
of ar and vr is going to be different
because you know you settle for
different things today but when you look
at what you can do with augment takes
you to a whole new different ball game
so it also create a different adaptation
of these technologies across all
millennials and different generations
and you know everyone's going to use it
right now give so give me maybe a few
examples of of how one might use dog
mind either in their studies in their
work you know i'm understanding that you
know one of the pain points that you're
solving here is that a lot of these
technologies for the next foreseeable
future they're going to require some
proprietary knowledge and some expertise
in order to really create these
immersive experiences that are high
quality and so you're bridging the gap
sort of like wix for websites canva for
designs augment for augmented reality
and mixed reality what are some
interesting use case in those domains
so if your focus for for a moment on on
the entities the companies the studios
the developers those who are in charge
of creating these apps and these kind of
contents uh
who are our target audience uh in the
first stage
uh is that in in a lot of cases you're
talking about you know technical people
creative people a lot of different
positions
within that studio within that company
who are in charge of the entire
production process
and in in many cases you're actually
looking for people who have a lot of
experience and know what they're doing
because
one of this one essentially one of the
main problems today is that you know if
you're trying to create
3d content right essentially
it's all 3d content it's either 3d
content for mobile devices or ar vr but
it's all 3d
and one of the major problem is that you
know if you're trying to create a
content let's take a car for example if
you're trying to model a car and show it
in ar and you want it to look real just
like the real thing
it's kind of difficult
because it's really heavy the content
when you create it it's so heavy that it
cannot run or perform on mobile devices
like your smartphone or head mount
display and so forth so what developers
trying to do is start reducing the level
of the content in technical terms means
reducing polygons etc
this is just one example of many but
this is one of the major problems so by
reducing those polygons eventually they
can at least adapt that content around
on your mobile device so you can look at
the ar content or app from your mobile
phone or your vr air glasses
and
that's time consuming it's costly and
eventually that car doesn't really look
like it should in reality so you also
sell for the graphics
completely completely if you're looking
at the next few years you know sort of
as a defining time for i think the
future of of ar vr and mixed realities
you know where are we heading you know
as a society consumer behavior you know
you're talking about a lot of these use
cases that right now you know we may be
able to imagine them but i think most of
society is still wrapping their head
around you know how is this actually
going to play in the in the in the
actual world how do you foresee consumer
behavior shifting in the next few years
um let's look at it two different
direction the coin side one being the
hardware
the other being the content the software
the hardware is how are you going to
look at it or you're going to use you
know start tearing your phone around
like this and look at it like that or
start putting you know the head mount
display the ones that exist today are
too bulky you can't really walk around
with them in the street right so you
have to use your phone uh next
generation is a lighter device that's
going to have the content transmitted
from your mobile phone so you're still
going to have to carry both you're going
to carry your your smartphone in your
pocket it's going to transmit and
eventually you know it's going to be
just like you know your average
sunglasses and the cpu and the gpu
everything is going to be on it you know
hopefully very soon
but
those kind of hardwares have their own
limitations in terms of the chips you
know the processing units the cpu and
the gpu um so they're heavily dependent
on what you're gonna play on them and
hence the content what is it that you're
gonna play
i believe that everything is going to be
on it eventually you're going to stop
using your smartphone the new platform
is going to move from smartphones to
smart glasses and everything is going to
be here and there are so many reasons to
it one being is that you know your
entire view is larger right it's not
just your screen from your phone you can
see everything plus you don't have to
hold it you have to carry it um it's
plugged into your ears in your eyes and
everything so it's so much easier um we
need to get there we need to get there
um soon and content has to follow if
you're gonna come up tomorrow with the
best headset you're still gonna need to
provide value for that device for it to
to work for users to buy it and start
using it um so it all coincides and
we're seeing already today that a lot of
different industries are using ar and vr
for
marketing for innovation um increase
their roi uh you know we had coved and
you know with different waves and you
know stores closed around the world and
companies looking for new ways of
selling etc um so it's shifting you're
already seeing that shift from you know
just you know regular website on the
internet you know to being able to
actually
see feel try on your new shoe etc um so
i think everything eventually is gonna
be
there we're gonna coincide the real
human beings with avatars we're gonna
have you know virtual conference goals
um you know we're already seeing the
visions of a lot of different companies
talking about it but it's in the making
it's in the happening
and i think that you know this is really
the best time to jump on the game
so obviously i can't ignore the the
expansion and excitement that you're
with which you're talking right now
where is this coming from where is this
excitement coming from right now for you
um several several directions uh for
starters um you know the team the team
that we've built internally
is it's a phenomenal team you know i've
been in multiple startups in the past
decade
and
what we did in augment we we built a
family here we built people that are so
connected to each other and we're having
fun we're we're creating things that
um arguably some of them don't even
exist yet and and it's an intriguing and
challenging but we're having fun doing
it so
i think one this is you know an
important indication the other is when
you actually finally finally you know
got to build it you know we raised a few
million dollars we've we've advanced we
created our initial product we went to
awe um a couple weeks ago which is the
largest ar vr conference in the world
show big companies what we can do you
know and that their eyes popped and said
well we we never knew this kind of
content existed
um
so we got some also some validation that
what we're doing is is amazing on the
right track it's all combined so you
know god willing on the right path if
you had to uh to guess or estimate what
what are some of the most
crucial challenges that you're going to
be facing yourself with your company in
the next short while what are some of
those
um for starters um
finding good people um you know uh you
probably heard you've probably seen um
you know all the big companies that are
running into you know their new next
metaverse and so forth they're gonna
need a lot of good people i mean
hopefully that's also where augment is
going to fit in and help them bridge
that gap um but you need good people and
good talent uh to build these kind of
technologies one of the main challenges
um
i think that um some of the
usual challenges if you will for for
startups is you know uh fundraising
marketing you know the doing the right
execution um even if you have the right
team and the right you know
capital you still need to have the right
execution and that depends um on how
well you succeed doing that um so we try
to bridge in you know the right plans
make sure we have the right plans where
uh so far you know thank god we're spot
on on the plans and you know it's
waiting for it to happen
i love it i love it and so if you know
for all the other young entrepreneurs
that are you know starting to think
about augmented reality or mixed
realities as you know a reality for a
startup what are some basic things that
you would recommend them
to to look into or to think more
critically about consumer behavior
before they go on this journey because
we're looking at the blue ocean right
now we're looking at a new space a new
field with that that you know there's a
lot of there's a lot of you know mess to
be made of which is very exciting but
it's also frightening on some level so
what would be some of your
recommendations there
i'll try to um make sure that you
understand the market first understand
um
where we're going where the markets are
going what is needed and
and try to foresee what's going to come
up in the the very uh near future and i
mean five years down the road running
right around the corner and especially
in these technologies things move so
fast so rapidly um so you know you don't
need to try to envision what's going to
happen three years from now just look at
six months now there are 12 months on
the road understand the markets um it's
easy it's easy it's not hard everything
is out there is available people talk
about all the time and come up with an
idea a solution um that's going to
change people's lives um
with one
with one major advice on that front um
don't try to change the entire world
tomorrow okay even if you have that
vision
at least come up with an intermediate
solution
that is quick and short to implement so
it's even easier for you because when we
were um three and a half years ago and
we tried to envision what we're gonna do
today um it was so big
and it took a lot of time to convince
people that we're on the right path
because we were ahead of the time
and so if you have an a good
intermediate idea that you can easily
implement that's going to give you a lot
of credit and also give you you know a
lot of different options to think about
are you really heading the right
direction
if we would have done it then it's
probably gonna solve a lot of the
problems that we were facing earlier
i love it and if you go back to your
childhood a little bit you know really
young you know elementary school middle
school
um what are you curious about what
really fascinated you as a kid and is it
connected at all to what you're doing
today
um i think so um well
i was
really social um i was really social and
you know i love people
uh a lot of in you know you know making
friends talking to everyone and and
it was a
it
it was interesting to talk to people and
see also what their vision where they're
going um come up with ideas together we
even have our had our own startup you
know back uh at
college that we started up and came up
with amazing ideas but i think it's kind
of like you know when when you're
meeting interesting people and you're
brainstorming you talk about you know
mutual ideas
um and i think that's one of the things
that fascinated me most
i love it and if you look today at your
day-to-day as an entrepreneur of an
early stage startup
where's the inspiration coming from you
know literally where you know where's
the inspiration today morning yesterday
morning
to to do what you're doing and to go
against all the different challenges
that obviously you're facing and there's
a lot of them
um there's just a lot of credit in you
know doing your own thing so um i know
it's kind of like a given but it's true
um
um it's also a lot a lot more difficult
than just being you know a night of
fiber and so forth but
um
you you have an idea you have a vision
and you get to build it how fascinating
is that i mean you have ideas all the
time even if you're you know you're
working you know
at the banks on wall street you have
your ideas and even if you're working at
startups you come up with other ideas so
forth but still you know there's another
captain to that ship and they're
navigating that ship and your ideas a
lot of times they're left behind and
you're still you know tied to that chip
you get to
you get to run your own ship in and you
know with all the challenges that come
with that and the responsibility but
that is fascinating because you know it
is up to you
and
you have you know
there's there's a lot of uh
interesting
ways where you can shift and navigate
that and i think this is one of the
coolest thing
that that's happening you know for us
for entrepreneurs in a startup you have
to be smart you have to be quick and you
have to you know you have to know what
you're doing and you have to you know
portray it the right way and there's so
many other challenges and so forth but
it's still at the end of the day it's
yours it's your dream
i love it and thank you so much for
spending these 20 minutes with me i
think that augmented reality mixed
reality virtual reality you know it's
going to eat the world by storm i think
the question is when and and we started
the conversation with a question of
timing and and i think you may be right
and we're going to discover that soon
and i think that you know it's going to
be an uphill battle no matter what
because it's shifting consumer behavior
and there's a lot of market education
and and i love the approach that you're
taking towards
enabling that that consumer behavior
change so ron thank you very very much
best of luck with augmind i really
appreciate your time thank you and stay
safe and stay healthy thank you
you